le président des sénateurs socialistes
et d'invités de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir didier guillot même soir michel
grossiord et merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec les
échos radio classique et l' agence
france-presse
et vous répondrai dans les 45 minutes
qui suivent à trois grandes questions
d'abord françois fillon et il en fait
votre meilleur adversaire vous le dirai
à jean francis pécresse
ensuite françois hollande ban manuel
valls qui est le mieux placé selon vous
pour 2017 la rivalité au sommet de
l'exécutif et existe bien sûr abordé
tout à l'heure par stéphanie le rouge
enfin le sénat est il devenu selon vous
depuis quelques temps le laboratoire du
sionisme questions posées tout à l'heure
par michael à metz mais d'abord une
première question d'actualité
on le sait avec les journalistes
françois hollande est il aussi
inconscient en mettant à leur
disposition des documents classés
confidentiel défense
non non mais ça c'est une supercherie
c'est un montage fait par la droite les
idées de droite notamment monsieur
ciotti qui est depuis dimanche soir a
beaucoup de temps pour s'occuper de la
destitution du président de la
république
non c'est une réalité ensemble ils ont
été publiées par les journaux et ça a
été publiée voilà ce n'est pas du tout
ce n'est pas du tout un problème du
président de la république
il a dit attendre de choses tout le
monde savait qu'il y avait des missions
en syrie tout le monde le savait rien
n'a été dévoilé donc voilà c'est je
pense que c'est un écran de fumée pour
faire oublier autre chose c'est dommage
je vais vous dire une chose quand on
passe son temps à dénigrer le président
de la république on dénigre la france
quand j'entends monsieur goasguen qui ce
matin des hollande dégage c'est pas la
hauteur du débat politique
faut pas s'étonner après si tous les
populismes si tous les extrémismes règne
en maître dans ce pays parce que le
président de la république qui a été élu
il a été élu par tous les français nous
sommes en fin de quinquennat et jusqu'au
mois de mai et les présidents de la
république dont il faut respecter la
fonction l'homme parce que nous
respectons la république et nous
respectons là on parle de révélations
qui font l'objet dit guillaume dunand
tête ou vers paris s'arrête aux
dirigeants ils sont obligés d'être
obligé à bord du man où la demande a été
faite par des députés et les
républicains d'ailleurs au départ il
avait annoncé que c'est tout le groupe
finalement il a beaucoup moins
et aussi des gens qui réfléchissent
savons joue pas comme cela on sait très
bien que cette destitution ne peut pas
exister ne peut pas arriver
c'est un coup politique mais à force de
faire des coups politiques on s'aperçoit
que les électeurs de la primaire n'ont
fait un endroit mais vous vous êtes
rassurés en quelque sorte vous voudrez
landiras jusqu'au bout de son mandat
rien eu beaucoup pas attendre les sûr
évidemment bien mais quand même vous dit
tout le monde savait évidemment que la
france voulait intervenir en syrie mais
de là à laisser publier des documents
sur une offensive qui était prévu donc
c'était en 2013
il n'y a pas qu'eux
le français qui avait été faite il n'y a
pas de révélation dans des danses
étaient à bord c'était un plan reid
ailleurs aucun nom mais donner aucun
lieu n'est donné simplement pas mis sur
un coup sûr pour être indigné les élus
républicains comme vous dites mais aussi
les militaires voire pour un dîner
républicain il s'indigne de beaucoup de
choses je veux dire une chose riche
grossiord convivialité de millions de
français devant leur télévision quand en
direct de la war room barraco il tuer
barack obama cherchant à dézinguer ben
laden donc faut arrêter cinéma tout ça
aujourd'hui chercher de devantures elle
qui n'en sont pas
moi je refuse de commenter les
polémiques
aujourd'hui on a mieux à faire de
polémique et nous agirons pays
la droite est dans sa primaire chacun
doit faire ce qu'il a à faire mais de là
à montrer toujours du doigt le même je
trouve que ça fait un couple en gros
nous dit françois hollande est un
président sans reproche un dans cette
affaire là un danseur que jean marc
ayrault avait dit à propos de la
révélation des opérations d'assassinats
ciblés à des terroristes à l'étranger
qu'effectivement ça n'a rien à voir mais
enfin on était quand même dans le
domaine militaire le domaine du
confidentiel du secret défense et jean
marc ayrault avait dit effectivement un
président devrait se taire je ne sais
pas ce qu'il est déjà marqué on se dit
ça arrive mais moi ça ne m'intéresse pas
ce que je sais c'est que le président
travaille et que ce que je sais ce que
nous sommes en guerre et valider des
faits de guerre voilà vous d'accord
alors votre d'essence était
effectivement livres assuré
mais ce que vous ne craignez pas quand
même pour lui à nouvelle effet d'image
ah mais ça vous savez aujourd'hui je ne
suis ni sourd ni aveugle je vois ce que
disent les français ce qu'ils y compris
les zus que 10 des femmes et des hommes
de gauche
je vois bien qu'il ya encore du travail
d'ici la fin du quinquennat il va
falloir le faire
combien c'est dur parfois d'être
toujours assurer la défense de tous tout
azimut la dune chef de l'état 10 ans
guillaume c'est le terme est dur
non parce que vous savez lorsqu'on est
parlementaire de la république française
rien n'est dur par rapport à ce que joie
pour mes enfants
par rapport à ce qu joie par adam là
dans la population rien n'est dur ce qui
est dur c'est d'être au chômage
ce qui est dur c'est de vivre dans la
précarité faire de la politique
lorsqu'on est passionné comme moi
lorsqu'on aime cela lorsqu'on aime un
peu bataille et on le respect des gens
et les autres m
un mot plus haut que l'autre vis-à-vis
des personnes n'est pas dur de toujours
tenir son rôle d'avocat on n'est pas du
tout au contraire 1 face à tous les
procureurs
c'est un bonheur de pouvoir de faire ce
travail côté je vous proposais après la
défense vous propose la tac avec la
première partie de l'épreuve de vérité
pour laquelle donc nous accueillons
jean-francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
jean françaix saint michel pour soir
didier guillot bonsoir alors est ce que
françois fillon est votre meilleur
adversaire ce dans l'hypothèse bien sûr
il serait confirmée dimanche prochain
lors de la primaire à droite
quelle surprise quelle surprise pour les
sondeurs quelle surprise pour les
journalistes
quelle surprise pour les responsables
politiques en voyait bien que françois
fillon remonter mais personne de penser
y compris peut-être lui-même y compris
ses plus proches qu'ils arriveraient à
44% qu'il arriverait à ce niveau là nous
n'avons pas à choisir nos adversaires
pour la pour l'élection présidentielle
ce n'est pas notre problème
d'ailleurs moi j'ai regretté que des
femmes et des hommes de gauche soit
aller voter et donner pour une chose et
il faut nous préserver d'un retour de
sarkozy bon je crois que les choses ont
été faites maintenant au deuxième tour
c'est la droite qui va choisir si c'est
françois fillon françois fillon pour la
première fois dans la vème république la
droite aura mis un candidat très à
droite le plus à droite de la vème
république
est ce que ça veut dire que vous appeler
clairement les sympathisants de gauche
ce soir à ne pas aller voter alain juppé
dimanche prochain à la main droite et
moi je n'ai pas appelé les gens sont
libres mais je ne leur demande est en
tout cas là mais je ne comprends pas que
lorsque l'on est de gauche on à y voter
à la primaire de la droite donc il me
semble que lorsqu'on est de gauche on ne
se déplace pas des manches peu importe
que ce soit alain juppé ou françois
fillon c'est le choix de la droite de
même que lorsque nous nous serons dans
notre primaire
j'espère je souhaite que je souhaite que
les femmes et les hommes de droite ne
viennent pas voter aux primaires parce
que c'est le choix d'un camp politique
est ce que c'est parce que au fond de
vous-même vous espérez bien avoir
françois fillon candidat de la droite
le 28e normes écoutez moi je moi je ne
me place pas dans ce concept là d'esprit
il ya une semaine ou dix jours personnes
pensent et françois fillon se met au 2e
tour et en user mais vous préférez alain
juppé ont nicolas sarkozy et déjà je
répondais je répondais peu importe la
force
vous avez répondu vous ai dit
s'il est élu ce sera le candidat le plus
à droite andré le candidat le plus à
droite c'est ça votre avantage
françois fillon c'est le candidat le
plus à droite quand on regarde le
programme aujourd'hui de la droite entre
alain juppé et françois fillon
globalement il ya les mêmes choses
globalement les mêmes choses on en
supprime ensuite l'une des
fonctionnaires on supprime les
fonctionnaires ont su développer et
fonctionne actionnaires 300 mille cinq
cent mille postes des fonctionnaires des
postes de fonctionnaires mais rendez
vous quand ken que supprimer 500 mille
postes de fonctionnaires ça veut dire
qu'on recrute plus d'une question
nationale dans la police dans la justice
dans la chaudronnerie c'est aberrant
comme l'a dit alain juppé
mais bien sûr bien sûr on a une plus
long écrit mais de postes de
fonctionnaires
comment il ne faut plus en supprimer
vous ne serez mais pas d'ailleurs vous
même nom sur le quinquennat depuis le
début 2012
vous avez fait plus trente mille
fonctionnaires de l'état
oui est ce que vous êtes content de ce
bilan par exemple non je ne suis pas
content c'est bidon j'en suis très fier
très fier et je le vois bandits comme
voir des cas et hommes de gauche d'avoir
mais vous dire pourquoi je crée nouveau
poste j'en veux revenir pourquoi parce
que quand nous créons 60000 postes dans
l'éducation nationale
car caen depuis 2012 il n'y a pas une
fermeture de classe unique en zone
rurale car depuis 2012 nous mettons des
moyens dans les zones quand la droite
quand la droite peut supprimer huit ou
neuf mille postes de policiers nous nous
en créons 13000 et je suis fier de cela
lorsque français parce que la france a
besoin de fonctionnaires pour la police
justement n'a jamais manqué le tir
derrière ogier sur son amant on ne
manque pas de regret allez dire aux
policiers les policiers on est un taux
de on est au départ subit de 58% et
l'allemagne qui a moins de moins de
fonctionnaires qui n'est pas réputé pour
être un pays à la traîne à 44 % de
dépenses plus mais vous savez 14 points
d'écart de 2 mg bid vous avez traîné ce
qu'on ne peut pas le faire un genre
encore que on manque de fonctionnaires
en france au nom non mais je n'ai pas
des sages la dépense publique pour la
fonction publique hautement de 700
millions d'euros par an 700 millions
d'euros par an si je peux me permettre
comment est-ce qu'on finance sarthe
françois fillon s'est répandue pourrait
rendre ayant si vous le savez pas
répondre je n'aurais pas dit par exemple
que nous nous endettons chaque année
pour rémunérer ses fastes des
fonctionnaires ou c'est faux c'est faux
c'est faux alors répondez jeu
parler de l'allemagne excusez moi de
vous dire vous êtes trop affûté pour
penser que cette comparaison ne vaut
rien pourquoi elle ne vaut rien votre
comparaison avec l'allemagne parce que
vous parlez de l'état fédéral et pas des
länder et si vous rajoutez l'état
fédéral et les länder
je connais bien l'allemagne je suis
germanophile on sait très bien qu'il ya
des fonctionnaires dans les länder
vous comprenez que l'état fédéral
nouilles en compte pas les régions en
compte mais sûre si on ne compte qu'un
petit bol nationale joue notre objectif
notre know me by men et non pas du tout
avec l'allemagne ne peut pas faire cette
comparaison
mais nous notre objectif ce n'est pas de
créer les fonctionnaires je peux vous
dire qu'un que de conneries fier d'en
avoir je suis très fier d'avoir créé ce
sont 1000 postes dans la dans
l'éducation nationale
je suis très fier qu'on a un bilan de +
13 mille postes dans les forces de
sécurité la justice parce que ça c'est
la règle était revenu en gironde les
gens nous le donne en ça mais nous en
nous sommes arrivés avec des déficits
nous étions à 5 % de dd mais si nous
allons être à 3%
monsieur fillon dit il faut passer à 4,2
non et dix mille 10 à 4 oui mais
peut-être mais quand on regarde le bilan
de ce quinquennat sur tout un tas de
sujets et notamment sur la dette ce qui
a augmenté la dette de 600 milliards
d'euros 600 milliards je sais pas si
vous rendez compte ce que c'est pendant
le quinquennat précédent
alors nous nous lavons diminué on ne
fait pas des leçons alors gestion en
revient au programme de françois fillon
et on voulait tester votre meilleur
adversaire
il est quoi françois fillon ils essaient
de chez rien pour vous il est très saine
chez rien il est libéral économiquement
et conservateurs socialement c'est
vraiment ce qui le caractérise le plus
possible je rappelle quand même le bilan
madame thatcher toute la dérégulation
notamment dans les transports
ferroviaires françois fillon il veut
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu pour les
familles aisées ou besson pour 12
millions de foyers fiscaux pour les
familles classement aux classes moyennes
il veut supprimer l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune en moi quand même sac une
idée très libéral
il veut augmenter la tva rendez vous
compte de 2% voire des camps ça veut
dire que le simple de deux points ça
veut dire que tous les français
lorsqu'ils vont acheter leurs produits
de premiers
nécessité vont être impactés par une
augmentation nous nous sommes refusés à
le à le faire on a parlé des
fonctionnaires il était on attendait on
a parlé de la tva sociale
nous pensons nous que c'est une ce que
parreira en baisse les cotisations que
c'est une et puis sur l'aspect
international
il aura à répondre à des questions et
sur la société sur la famille
j'ai compris d'ailleurs depuis ce matin
et a entendu monsieur raffarin entendu
monsieur juppé lui-même que dans le
débat et dans les meetings on va avoir
des questions sur la famille sur les
questions sociétales et sur
l'international parce que sur
l'international
ça peut être un renversement d'alliance
et un changement de pied par rapport
notamment à la russie de monsieur
poutine
et là il faudra qu'il s'explique alors
on va parler des 35 heures je vous
propose d'écouter françois fillon dire
qu'effectivement il veut revenir sur
cette mesure emblématique de la gauche
je considère que les 35 heures c'est une
des raisons des très graves difficultés
que nous rencontrons aujourd'hui non
seulement parce que les 35 heures ont
fait baisser la compétitivité de
l'économie française donc ont provoqué
du chômage et parce que les 35 heures
ont généré des coûts notamment en
matière de dépenses publiques à cause de
la baisse du travail dans le secteur
public donc il faut revenir sur les 35
heures tout le monde à droite est à peu
près d'accord sur ce constat là en quoi
est-ce qu'il est plus libérale sur ce
sujet là que d'autres candidats que
alain juppé par exemple n'en sur ce
sujet là je crois pas qu'ils aient
beaucoup de différences entre eux je
crois qu'il ya des différends sur la la
durée moyenne de travail à la semaine
puisque lui il voudrait mettre quarante
huit heures pour enfin revenir sur les
35 heures pour redresser à 39 heures
c'est pas une avancée sociale ce qui
c'est qui va qui va ramasser qui c'est
qui va prendre c'est toujours les mêmes
c'est toujours les plus faibles
je ne vois pas l'intérêt alors
évidemment il dit je pars avant de son
programme 2010 pour mais c'est le nombre
de fonctionnaires à 500000 il faut
augmenter le temps de travail pour
qu'ils travaillent plus plus d'accord va
très bien dans ces pays plus aussi c'est
pas notre jeu minéral j'espère bien
qu'ils travaillent 39 sont payées 39 à
35 heures c'est ce que lui disait
nicolas sarkozy françois précise-t-on en
programme parce que si pour faire 39
heures payées 35 alors là c'est plus que
c'est plus qu'un recul
non je crois qu'aujourd'hui
eh bien les économistes qui sont en
train de dire que le programme de
françois fillon s'il était appliqué
c'est moi un point moi un point de
croissance
donc on se retrouverait en décroissance
avance bien sûr qu'avec eux notre taux
de croissance actuel david 1 3 avec
quelques rides
oui mais nous nous l'avons maintenu vous
entendre sur les questions sociales ou
sociétales plus exactement et notamment
savoir ce que vous pensez de la
polémique à droite qui oppose alain
juppé maintenant et françois fillon sur
libé g est ce que vous pensez vous aussi
que françois fillon est une menace pour
le droit fondamental à l'avortement en
france
non moi je ne peux pas de langue de bois
ou du combat politique politicienne
non je ne crois pas et je pense que
franchement ce débat afin si l'on va si
toute la semaine on se tape un débat à
part pour parler des questions très
importantes n 2 li vg de la pma de la
gpa je pense que les français veulent
qu'on peut l'entendre
autre champ vous dites on fait un
mauvais procès à françoise si oui je
alors oui on fait un mauvais procès à
leurs clients parce que je pense que
c'est exagéré de passer une journée déjà
une journée entière là dessus que moi
mais et puis ça va continuer si j'ai
bien compris j'aime bien entendu sur
votre plateau tout à l'heure le débat
qui nous précédaient mais faut
reconnaître que françois fillon est
soutenu par la manif pour tous par sens
commun il fait partie de cette droite
catholique traditionnelle ou
traditionalistes et que évidemment il
n'a rien à lui resté avec un malin nord
il a pris des engagements donc moi je
respecte ses engagements est née je n'y
reviendrai pas bon a très bien mon tacle
de jeunes rats polémiquer sur des choses
qui n'avaient pas la peine mais nous
serons vigilants parce que peut-être qu
autour de lui il est poussé par des gens
qui voudraient revenir là dessus c'est
tout enfin je pense franchement c'est un
sujet qu'il faut purger pour l'un et
pour l'autre
mais il ya d'autres sujets à aborder au
cours de la primaire de la droite et du
centre que de parler toute la semaine de
la fin quand même c'est un sujet
important
je conviens dévorer
ce que vous voyez notre confrère laurent
joffrin ce matin dans libération écrire
que françois fillon serait un ramadhan
des sacristies c'est une allusion aux
prédicateurs des frères musulmans est ce
que vous pensez que il va beaucoup trop
loin
ou est ce que c'était il ya une part de
vérité là de trajet vous dire une chose
chez moi dans la drôme leur dire
françois fillon le temps ramadan des
halles à christie savoir personne c'est
ce que savait bien non ça ne m'intéresse
pas moi je ne parle que de choses dont
je pense qu'elles peuvent être comprises
dans la voyait les actions voilà oui on
non mais il fait le porno on pourrait
faire les frais 6 et le directeur nommé
d'accord mais alors il sait pas d'accord
mais votre réponse est par exemple si on
vous dit également que dans cet édito
n'est ce pas jean francis laurent
joffrin fait le parallèle entre l'islam
politique et les prises de position
aujourd'hui de françois fillon est ce
que ça vous indigne je ne voulais pas
tomber sur l'avortement je voulais pas
être langue de bois je ne suis pas là
pour commenter les études les accros de
la presse quotidienne nationale qu'est
ce que vous espérez pour le débat de
jeudi soir vous espérez qu'alain juppé
écrabouille françois fillon ne nous
j'espère qu'il y aura un débat
intéressant vous savez je vais vous dire
une chose c'est pareil pour nous pour le
débat de notre primaire qui viendra fin
janvier peut-être apprendrons-nous tout
à l'heure un débat à 7
franchement les débats ont duré deux
heures et demie ils ont parlé 14 à 15
minutes chacun c'est très compliqué
d'organiser un débat de primaire à sept
candidats là au moins ils seront 2 les
deux finalistes
ils auront du temps pour s'interpeller
pour répondre aux questions des
journalistes
et pour se poser plein de questions
entre eux ce sera beaucoup plus
intéressant me semble-t-il est beaucoup
plus claire comment est-ce que vous
analysez vous le résultat de dimanche
soir est ce que c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour la gauche ou pour françois
hollande en particulier ou une nouvelle
tout mettre au fond est ce que ce sont
les sortants qui saute ou la possibilité
pour françois hollande de en partant
très bas de faire un score extrêmement
de ça peut être les deux
qu'est ce que je vous dise personne
n'avait vu cette remontée de françois
fillon le fait qu'il arrive quasiment à
50% dès le premier tour moi je fais un
syndrome d' analyse une analyse que la
vérité paye que françois fillon il n'a
pas fait beaucoup de bruit la préfet de
mousse mais il avait un programme
claire il a eu à me semble-t-il
bénéficié du vote utile et il est monté
comme cela j'en tire pas d'enseignements
pour pour la gauche c'est un
enseignement pour la droite il faut en
tirer pour la gauche nous verrons bien
nous lorsqu'on nous connaîtrons les
candidats comment les choses se
passeront quand vous ne comprenez pas
les électeurs de gauche qui se rendent à
la première de la droite mais pour ceux
qui vont finalement secrètement votre
enfin votre envie serait qui vote plutôt
sion donc votre meilleur adversaire non
non non ça ne m'intéresse pas cp non
franchement je n'ai pas donné de
consigne parce que je ne vois pas
pourquoi nous aurions à choisir entre
l'un ni l'autre puisque les deux
programmes se ressemblent beaucoup
hormis les questions sur lesquelles nous
venons de de parler avec jean francis
merci beaucoup
jean-francis deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité avec stéphanie le
rouge de l' agence france presse qui
nous rejoint l'épreuve de vérité avec la
fp
non soit stéphanie merci d'être avec
nous votre question président des
sénateurs ps ici au sénat oui on nous
souhaitons savoir si pour vous françois
hollande est le meilleur candidat on ne
peut être manuel valls puisque celui ci
depuis en plus à l'offensive
françois hollande et manuel valls sont
les deux meilleures candidates nous
pouvons avoir un
donc pour moi les choses sont très
claires il n'y a pas à les opposer
il n'y a pas posé ces questions le
président de la république a dit qu'il
donnerait sa réponse le 10 décembre
s'il est candidat je le soutiendrai pas
ce qu'il est capable de porter le bilan
de son quinquennat qui a été décrié tout
au long de ce quinquennat
à gauche comme à droite d'ailleurs parce
que les fraudeurs ne nous ont pas aidés
mais dans ce quinquennat sera
revalorisée j'en suis certain j'en suis
certain s'il est candidat je le
soutiendrai
et s'il n'est pas candidat eh bien je
pense que c'est manuel valls qui est
celui qui devra prendre le flambeau
parce qu'il a été ministre pendant cinq
ans et là il a été premier ministre
depuis 2014 mais moi je ne veux pas
participer au débat de choisir l'un ou
l'autre parce qu'en fait
institutionnellement la question ne va
pas se poser
ils vont pas être candidats l'un contre
l'autre ou de l'un face à l'autre ou
l'un à côté de l'autre ce sont les
institutions une fois que le président
de la république qui aura fait son choix
sa position à vème république
eh bien les choses se décanteront et
enfants vous pensez que sa position
actuelle
qu'elle est n je ne sais pas quoi
attendre trois semaines que c'est un peu
lent non voilée dans mes tours semaine
dans l'entourage en armes et à isoler me
dire trouve que ça suffit cette course
de lenteur
mais c'est pas une course de lenteur il
a fixé le calendrier j'avais dit je
crois chez vous d'ailleurs que ici même
à public sénat que le président de la
république est le maître de l'horloge
appartement il a dit qu'il donnerait sa
réponse mais avant la mi décembre
donnera sa réponse à voir la mi décembre
maintenant marie le guen que manuel
valls doit se tenir prêt non non non non
justement c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire votre question tombe bien j'ai dire
qu'une nous nous devons nous tenir prêts
parce qu'il suffit pas d'attendre comme
ça comme les anoraks la position d'intel
d'intel qu'est ce qui se passe le jour
où il se déclare que faisons-nous commun
avançons nous et la stratégie des
socialistes de ceux qui soutiennent le
président de la république de ce qu'ils
sont ce que l'on appelle la gauche de la
réforme la gauche de gouvernement les
sociaux démocrates
c'est de préparer la primaire dès la
gauche laurent qui aura lieu le 22 et le
29 janvier c'est ça notre et si tous les
socialistes la nôtre aujourd'hui
maintenant à l'heure où on parle et le
10 août 15 décembre se met à travailler
sur le fond sur l'organisation
l'archictecture de telle ou telle
candidature je pense que les choses
avanceront mieux alors nous ne restons
pas l'armé au pied et ne ne cherchons
pas opposés l'un à l'autre ça n'a aucun
sens ils ne peuvent pas être opposés
parce qu'ils ne sont ni concurrents ni
adversaire alors qu'ils sont tous les
deux des normes d'énormes qualités
le président de la réveiller une place
bordeu un seuil a qu'une place à
l'arrivée donc le présent de la réplique
donnera sa sa réponse il est candidat ce
sera lui vous pensez que manuel valls
peut jouer le rôle de rassembleur de la
gauche parce qu'il a quand même l'image
de quelqu'un d'extrêmement clivant il
n'avait fait que 5 % à la primaire de
il reste identifié à la droite du ps
quand même non mais c'est le premier
ministre de la france
il est comptable du quinquennat
puisqu'il a été pendant cinq ans
au gouvernement qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pendant ces 4 c 5 ans pourquoi je
vous dis que ce bilan va être
revalorisée j'ai mis sur mon papier 5,6
points les inégalités elles ont baissé
les finances ont été redressés
l'économie a été à redémarrer notre
modèle social a été préservé la sécurité
sociale est équilibré et l'école est
devenue la pole la priorité voilà c'est
laid ce sont des orientations de gauche
si là dessus ce gouvernement il ya des
millions de personnes dont 2 fois des
millions avec le travail si on cumule
les très nombreux alors dans ces cas là
si vous voulez à avoir le record du
monde vous ajouter ceux qui ont été mis
dans la rue par alain juppé par françois
fillon
mais là c'est des dizaines de millions
de personnes sur la durée d'ouverture de
records donc je me rends parfois les
records de mai on attend le chiffre mais
aujourd'hui la courbe du chômage s'est
inversée aujourd'hui il y a plus de
demain de 2,2 marder d'emplois qu'il n'y
en avait en 2012 parce qu'il y a plus de
gens sur le marché qui n'en avaient en
aujourd'hui lille s'est mis l'insee le
dit très bien
le chômage a baissé pour la première
fois depuis les années 90 autant mais
moi je n'aime pas parler de cela parce
que en fait on est le choix c'est pas
tellement dans le bilan de chômage
celui-ci mais je peux vous les pourquoi
parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse ce sont
les femmes et des hommes c'est la pâte
humaine
quand on dit le chômage baisse de 65
mille îles a baissé sur l'année il aura
baisser le chômage aura baissé sur
l'année nous avons gagné notre pari
mais c'est rien par rapport à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui sont demandeurs
d'emploi qui sont au chômage qui
souffrent alors stéphanie évoqué il ya
un instant le ministre proche de manuel
valls jean marie le guen il était sur
radio classique ce matin il évoquait les
hommes d'état à gauche et écoutés ils
pensent comme vous ils sont pas si
nombreux ils envoient te fous ici à
gauche il n'y a pas 150 hommes d'état je
suis pas psy en avait 150 à droite et
même 7 mais en tout état de cause à
gauche
à mon sens il y en a deux filles à
manuel valls et françois hollande
alors vous avez noté ici d'abord et en
deux françois hollande mais moi je vous
dis à françois hollande et manuel valls
d'accord là mais c'est ce que vient de
dire jean marie le guen est important
parce que la primaire n'a de sens que
lorsque l'on regarde les candidats et
qu'on se dit est-ce que lui ou elle
peuvent faire le job est ce qu'ils
peuvent être président de la république
et moi je pense que dans la primaire de
la droite que nous venons de voir ils
n'étaient pas 7 après avoir la capacité
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas demain mais
aujourd'hui ils n'étaient pas cet apport
est maintenant mais je pense qu'un avait
3 et que ces trois là sont arrivés aux
trois premières places ce qui est
logique
vous savez les gens il regarde les
choses aussi et le renouveau la
nouveauté les choix solitaire ça marche
bien ça fait des comètes des comètes
personnel et nous amener sur le terrain
du ça fait un moment que ça fait un
moment que j'essaie de vous y emmener
mais vous ne réagissez pas donc j'ai la
justice avec mes gros sabots
je vais vous dire à gauche je vais vous
dire à gauche aujourd'hui il y aura je
sais pas combien 4 5 6 7 8 candidats à
la primaire de la gauche mais qui peut
être président de la république
certains préparent le prochain congrès
du parti socialiste d'autres prêts font
des destins individuels mais aujourd'hui
il faut être président de la république
il faut lutter contre le terrorisme
il faut parler avec donald trump et
vladimir poutine je suis désolé mais
aujourd'hui à gauche et tant mieux
d'ailleurs
tant mieux sont pas si nombreux que ça
pour être présentés sur les autres
candidats déjà déclarés récupérer sur
emmanuel macron dans la candidature
or primaire est irrévocable il l'a
répété oui mais est-ce que emmanuel
macron pour vous va être celui qui va
enterrer la gauche du fait de cette
division
ben si emmanuel macron continue ce choix
solitaire vac jusqu'au bout comme il l'a
dit vous savez l'élection présidentielle
ce encore très loin mais si il dépose sa
candidature avec les 500 parrainages
ça veut dire qu'il fait le choix de la
victoire de la droite en presque ils
devraient discuter avec nous jean
christophe cambadélis
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste lui a dit emmanuel vient dans
la primaire de la gauche qu'il vienne
dans cette primaire il se dit je suis ni
de droite ni de gauche
faire comme conclusion à la primaire de
la droite que les partis politiques sont
morts au moment où les républicains à
organiser une primaire de plus de 4
millions de personnes
excusez moi de vous dire que c'est un
peu hardie comme raisonnement également
sur le clivage droite gauche vous vous
estimez qu'il est vide on les écoute et
on apprend réalisé par seth dans la
première partie
dans la première partie de l'émission
devront parler du programme de françois
fillon
ceux qui pensent qu'il n'ya pas de
différence entre la droite et la gauche
se mette le doigt dans l'oeil
oui je vais vous demander entre françois
hollande et manuel valls
est ce que l'un pour vous est mieux
placé que l'autre pour empêcher une
éventuelle candidature de maquereaux non
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas des
harkis sont des hollandais non non non
mais il n'y a pas d'argument savait faux
la politique qu'il faut pas faire de la
petite politique aguerri les trucs de
boutiques ça ne marche pas faut
s'adresser aux françaises et aux
français au peuple pour l'instant
emmanuel macron est sur son nuage il a
fait des marches il a fait du
porte-à-porte il est candidat
très bien il faut que celles et ceux qui
le soutiennent se rende compte qu'il n'a
pas il ne peut pas arriver au bout il
n'a pas d' espace politique
il y aura une droite peut être un
candidat du centre et un candidat
socialiste et d'extrême gauche et
d'extreme droite emmanuel macron ne peut
pas être en l'air en lévitation tout le
temps moi je regrette emmanuel macron
doit faire porter de notre dispositif
il a travaillé à l'elysée sous
l'autorité du président de la république
pendant des années il a été ministre n'a
pas été facile toujours de défendre la
loi macron moi je les défends du jour
que jusqu'au bout et je n'ai pas
démissionné avant la fin même quand je
me suis fait beaucoup secoué les parlers
par les gens m'en a d'ailleurs voulu
mais lui il a voulu trop bien la maison
né parvient à la maison je suis dit
emmanuel si tu veux que la gauche
l'un porte à la présidentielle il faut
que nous soyons rassemblés mais vous
fréquentez vous voyez souvent le chef de
l'état françois hollande est ce qu il a
perdu tout espoir de le ramener à mais
je ne sais pas mais à la raison en ligne
sa raison je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
ramener emmanuel macron à la raison
c'est à lui de prendre ses
responsabilités on va pas faire la danse
du ventre de devant lui aura pas lui
promettre je ne sais pas quoi y'a rien à
promettre aujourd'hui dans le jeu est
clair c'est que marine le pen est aux
portes du pouvoir dans ce pays et je
pense que la gauche est plus à même que
la droite de l'empêcher d'arriver au
pouvoir
est ce que valent c'est pas mieux manuel
valls pardon n'est pas mieux placé que
françois hollande pour justement faire
baisser le score éventuelle de
monsieur macro et donc peut-être le
contraindre toute façon on regardera
nous regarderons les comment les choses
seront après la désignation de notre
candidat le 29 janvier 22 29 janvier le
départ il sera là pour l'instant des à
l'échauffement le match n'a pas démarré
la droite aura son candidat
dimanche soir essayons de faire campagne
de novembre à avril mais nous avons vu
ça après les primaires de 2011 nous nous
avons notre candidat le 29 janvier et
bien c'est le 30 janvier que les choses
démarrent donc d'ici là chacun quand ses
troupes chacun regarde mais le 30
janvier
une fois que nous allons partir avec
notre notre candidat mais il faudra que
chacun assume le combat droite gauche je
veux je veux le dire ce qui nous
racontait qu'il n'y avait plus de
clivage entre la droite et la gauche que
du ni droite ni gauche est une réalité
lorsqu'on regarde les programmes qui
sont là si on pense que nous avons des
du travail possible à faire en commun
avec françois fillon sur les sujets que
nous avons évoqués je crois que c'est
une erreur
on nous avons plein de sujets communs
avec la droite républicaine notre pays
la défense de la nation le patriotisme
on va prolonger l'état d'urgence
nous sommes des élus et des femmes et
des hommes responsables mais sur le
programme économique et social
nous ne sommes pas sur la même ligne
alors vous êtes adressé amène et même à
cran il ya une minute dix derniers ou
mais vous n'avez pas répondre à notre
question selon vous qui est le mieux
placé pour 2017 entre françois hollande
et manuel valls mais vous le savez très
bien manuel valls lui il s'estime le
mieux placé il plaide pour son cas en ce
moment
alors qu'est ce que vous lui dites au
premier ministre je ne je n'ai pas dû
dire quoi que ce soit excusez moi vous
poser des questions que auquel je ne
réponds pas ça fait la deuxième fut mais
le 10 décembre
je dis à tous les socialistes restons
tranquilles
restons sereins travaillons rassemblons
nous nous avons face à nous une droite
qui se durcit et qui se droitise voir
sur certains sujets ce extrême droite is
anneau de faire bloc et de montrer aux
français qu'il ya une différence entre
la gauche et la droite entre le
programme est ce que nous en ferons la
question parce que lui manuel valls il
voit une différence entre lui et
françois hollande en a il ya quelques
jours
la stella semaine dernière et ira leur
ville il a dressé le portrait robot vous
l'avez entendu un du candidat de gauche
pour 2012 et il doit avoir les qualités
suivantes la méthode la rigueur
l'engagement personnel l'incarnation et
l'autorité est en fait c'est ce sont
entre belges et légère je vais vous dire
je pense que françois hollande comme
toutes les cases là parce que affronter
du quinquennat comme il a eu un des plus
durs c'est le générique on craint
déclinons mais ça c'est vrai ça c'est
votre analyse votre commentaire c'est
pas une critique en creux dans lorsqu'il
fait ce profil type
c'est un profil type qui correspond qui
correspond aux deux le président de la
république s'il décide d'être candidat
le dise le 10 décembre sera soutenue par
une immense majorité et par manuel valls
est modestement par moi même et s'il ne
dessine pas nous serons dans une autre
phase oui françois hollande
les sondages montrent qui peut perdre
face à monteux arnaud montebourg est-ce
que les socialistes qui ont soutenu la
ligne gouvernementale dont vous faites
partie peuvent se permettre de laisser
le parti arnaud montenon la s'agit pas
du parti il s'agit de parce que le parti
limite je dirais c'est moins grave
là il s'agit d'incarner quelque chose
pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle
et je vous réponds non je réponds non à
votre question nous pouvons pas je peux
me semble-t-il
s'il était désigné la démocratie
s'exprimerait mais avant le 29 janvier
nous devons tout faire tout pour que la
ligne réformiste l'emportent les
équilibres de ce pays nous avons mis en
place aujourd'hui s'est pas portée dans
une aventure extrême gauchisé je
m'excuse 2d d'appeler un chat un chat
donc aujourd'hui nous en sommes au chili
la wii et quel crédit apporter vos
sondages qui donnent françois hollande
battu emmanuel comme ceux de comme ceux
d'hillary clinton et de juppé la semaine
dernière je nous verrons bien
oui oui mais vous êtes persuadé quand
même que comme pour fillon un sondage ne
dit jamais la vérité six mois avant une
élection bien sûr ça va bien sûr j'en ai
déjà parlé évidemment je ne sais pas qui
sera élu président de la république par
an le 6 mai ou en mai
2010 est une chose dont je suis persuadé
et que je vois depuis trois-quatre jours
c'est que la semaine dernière quand j'ai
rencontré les sénateurs socialistes et
d'autre il me disait je crois bien que
c'est foutu
depuis lundi je pense que c'est jouable
merci stéphanie troisième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
michaël szames s2 public sénat on sait
qu'elle soit 108 yens 110 et guillaume
bonsoir alors la question gérard larcher
vous voulez faire du csna le laboratoire
de l'alternoce est ce qu'il est devenu
le laboratoire de françois fillon
non je pense que c'est plus un
laboratoire c'est le cimetière des
éléphants est ce que nous sommes mais je
vais vous expliquer je pense que le rôle
premier d'un parlementaire c'est de
siéger essaie notamment de voter le
budget
la droite a fait un choix ça voulait pas
digérer ça et je n'ai pas digéré
quand on pense au nombre de gens à
droite comme à gauche qui veulent
supprimer le sénat
quand la droite supprime le budget au
sénat que reste-t-il
et donc je crois vraiment que par
rapport à ce que dit le président gérard
larcher pour lequel j'ai plus le plus
grand respect c'est instamment président
du sénat il n'y a pas de sujet mais il
disait nous voulons construire le budget
de l'alternance est là pour des raisons
politiques et politiciennes nous ne
seront pas amenés à voter le budget à
aborder le budget même pas comme il
l'avait fait en 2012 et 2013 au moins la
première partie rien rien du tout la
droite refuse le débat car elle ces
jeunes affirme ce soir elle sait que les
propositions dont nous venons de parler
c'est été mis là sur la table
aujourd'hui leur servirait pas pour
l'élection présidentielle
ils sont capables de sa part et si vous
l'avez nord aujourd'hui on disait comme
les enfants disent je peux pas venir
j'ai piscine aujourd'hui ce que dit la
la la droite sénatoriale c'est moi je
peux pas venir j'ai primaire nous voilà
bien que politique vous dites en quelque
sorte que la primaire s'est invitée au
sénat elle est victime un petit peu de
cette primaire
la primaire s'est invitée au sénat et le
sénat est victime de la primaire et de
fait la conséquence c'est qu'il n'y aura
pas de budget et je pense que ce n'est
pas bien
du tout pour le sénat c'est une pour les
sénateurs c'est une faute politique
qu'il croit faute grave
alors bien entendu par rapport à tout ce
que l'on voit là aujourd'hui il faut
relativiser ce mais je pense que saddam
ne parle dans ce populisme dans ce
populisme dans tout ce qu'ils montrent
du doigt les parlementaires tous ceux
qui montrent du doigt le sénat john cena
ne sert à rien ça coûte cher
il ya une deuxième chambre ne pas siéger
pour voter le budget parce qu'on va
siéger lors des débats des discussions
pour occuper la galerie pour que public
sénat puisse tourner c'est l'après midi
son émission 360 etc
c'est pour ça qu'ils font ça je suppose
c'est pas à la hauteur de l'événement
vraiment nous aurions aimé nous aurait
aimé nous qu'en 2011
rappelez vous lorsque nous avons pris
nous avons été majoritaires au sénat
le plf 2012 nous avons fait le plf de
l'alternance nous et aujourd'hui ils
prennent des prétextes fallacieux en
disant article 40 ce n'est pas possible
c'est faux et qu'elle nous dise qu le
budget est insincère électoraliste
rendez le sincère mais baisser le nombre
de fonctionnaires le budget des
fonctionnaires augmenter la augmenter la
tva c'est fort c'est fort possible
passez aux 39 heures mais ils ne veulent
pas le faire parce qu'ils savent très
bien qu'aujourd'hui ils sont dans leurs
primaires et il s'adresse à la droite et
la droite je pense peut se retrouver sur
ce programme de cassure sociale savait
et alain juppé en 1995 lorsqu'il était
premier ministre parce qu'il faut se
rappeler était premier ministre en 1995
il ya 22 ans 21 ans il voulait se battre
contre la fracture sociale
là il veut assumer la cassure sociale et
françois fillon qui a toujours voulu
dire
du sang et des larmes faut dire la
vérité aux français j'ai un pays en
faillite mais là aujourd'hui il n'y pas
que les comptes sont redressés et
françois fillon dit on va leur en faire
baver et notamment aux plus vulnérables
et bien ce dont vous vous demandez ce
soir de tout mettre sur la table surtout
sur la table les nounous se déprécier
leur budget nous sommes prêts et nous
sommes prêts il travaillait à participer
nous en avons parlé en commission dès
des finances allez-y cet après midi
c'était absolument ahurissant ce qui
s'est passé nous étions en commission
des finances pour aborder le budget des
collectivités territoriales avec deux
amendements qui était présenté par les
rapporteurs de la commission
alors que on ne va pas en débattre ça
n'a aucun sens mais aucun sens
alors parce que nous sommes des images
de dieu parce que nous sommes des du
responsable nous allons commission nous
disons que nous ne partageons pas leur
leur avis d'ailleurs la présidente de la
commission des finances l'a dit tout à
l'heure
il ya beaucoup de budget qui ont été
votées en commission des finances mais
chaque fois que la droite c'est à
sénatoriales vote contre un budget elle
veut pas contre parce que ce budget est
trop important il dépense trop elle vote
comme parce qu'elle jamais assez jamais
assez ce n'est pas seulement
quelle image cela renvoie sur le sénat
et est ce que vous estimez qu'il ya une
part de responsabilité de la part du
président du sénat ah oui bien sûr il ya
une part de responsabilité président
gildas moi je pense que le président du
sénat aurait dû imposer imposé que le ce
débat se tienne et ce budget sera moins
historique à moins qu'ils le fassent
mais peut-être je vous dis ils étaient
trop occupés par leur primaire peut-être
qu'ils ont préfet prioriser la primaire
au au budget je crois que c'est
regrettable
un parlementaire qui n'a pas accès au
budget qui ne peut pas en débattre voter
les recettes de l'état votée les
dépenses ne fait pas son boulot honnête
mais vous dites donc ses responsabilités
aussi également du président du sénat ba
écarté le délit d' entrave numérique
c'est un texte qui était dans l'égalité
citoyenneté pour expliquer côté
spectateurs et qui touche notamment ali
vg notamment pour interdire les sites
qui prône lives et j'ai là aussi vous
diriez que le sénat et conservateurs oui
mais le sénat est terriblement
conservateurs c'est pour ça que nous
l'avons redéposer jeu les redéposer dans
un espace réservé comme on appelle de
notre groupe nous allons débattre dans
les
l'essai qui se brisaient sont allés
chercher 10 udc sakura livre gc ca il
s'agit pas là encore vous voyez ça
ressemble un peu avec le débat qu'on a
que nous avons eu de salaire en début
d'émission sur les positions de françois
fillon qui est ultra majoritaires au
sénat
il ya une volonté très rétrograde très
très poussiéreuses de la société bien
sûr que on tourne défendent tous la
famille d'aujourd'hui la famille et les
multiples la famille c'est un homme une
femme ses deux hommes ces deux femmes
c'est comme cela et on ne peut pas
revenir en arrière et on ne peut pas
imposer aux citoyens ce que l'on
voudrait avoir en tête et ce que l'on a
appris quand on était petit ça ne marche
pas comme cela dit guillaume il ya trois
ans presque trois ans gérard larcher a
été élu il ya eu des changements quand
même au sénat il ya eu pas mal de
modifications sanctions financières pour
les absents fonctionnement transparent 2
du parlement diriez vous que l'image du
sénat a changé oui je pense que oui oui
nous avons nous avons voté ces
changements sans aucun problème alain
richard le sénateur socialiste avec
roger karoutchi entravé d'un set dans
cette direction moi ça va c'est moi je
ne cherche pas le clivage pour que
l'image je pense que si on était si on
est conscient de ce qui se passe dans le
monde
trump l'élection en autriche le
référendum en italie ce qui se passe
dans les pays bas etc
c'est l'extrême droite monde de partout
les populismes monte de partout et je
crois que notre vieille façon de faire
de la politique de dire à 12h06 indices
et blanc l'autre 10 et noirci fait nuit
on dit qu'il fait jour ça n'a plus de
raison d'être
il faut revenir au fond au fond du vrai
débat moi je me voyais gora sln fiche
d'un tel un d'intel si les bras ainsi
les blancs si les noirs si les blancs
c'est pas le sujet on n'en est pas là
dans un casting on est là pour montrer
aux français quelle est notre politique
et notre politique c'est ce sont des
actions ce sont des actes comme nous
l'avons évoqué tout à l'heure et quand
ce que fait le sénat c'est bien nous le
votons pour son fonctionnement interne
et vous savez je crains que tout cela
tout cela soit balayée malheureusement
que l'on repart trois ans qu'on prenne
encore de trois ans de retard parce qu
on ne votera pas le budget parce que les
français qui s'intéressent à la
politique vont quand même se rendre
compte que nous ne voterons pas le
budget alors on vous écoute des débuts
où vous descendez le sénat l'image du
sénat
mais hitler il ya aujourd'hui un élu
socialiste du sénat qui considère qu'une
décision de son parti va à l'encontre
justement de ce combat que vous menez
pour l'image et la crédibilité de cette
assemblée c'est david assouline
on les écoute car il va perdre
manifestement son poste il est très
contrarié de devoir céder sa place à
daniel vaillant ce qui est désolant
aussi c'est que c'est la façon dont on
considère le sénat lui même
ce n'est pas la chambre des retraités de
l'assemblée nationale en fin de 2 de
plusieurs mandats est ici c'est une
chambre en tant que tel j'ai essayé de
danny messer débarque vous savez alors
respect du sénat d ivry un instant à
propos de l'examen du budget respondi
sénat du dividende solide nous avons
entendu que répondez vous j'ai entendu
oui je suis à la fois surpris parce
qu'il faut pas se parler comme cela
entre entre amis entre camarades
je ne sais pas ce qui va être ce qui va
être décidé à paris c'est une décision
purement purement locale donc le sénat
s'est pas remettre tel député qu'il y
ait ici men a beaucoup qui sont venus
déjà deux députés mais ce n'est pas
encore ce que ce n'est pas reconduire à
vis des sénateurs non plus donc c'est
pas ça le sujet moi je
david assouline fait du bon travail au
sénat je veux le dire après ce qui se
passe à la fédération de paris state 107
1 800 adhérents sur le renouvellement de
la classe politique c'est peut-être ce
qu'il a voulu dire une oreille alors là
pour le coup le renouvellement de la
classe politique on le sent reçoit
personnes nous mettons des candidatures
paritaire ce n'est pas leur cas il ya
plus de femmes de gauche que de que de
femmes de droite
le renouvellement de jeunes dans la
diversité pas la maison de retraite de
l'assemblée nationale le sénat est une
est une institution qui est importante
mais au sénat il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de députés je sais pas si le
président larcher n'a pas idée députés
avant d'être sénateur mais il ya
beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de députés
qui viennent la pressé c'est pas
prennent deux autres ne savait dire que
le sénat est une maison de retraite déjà
c'est commettre une énorme erreur ça
allait dans le sens de ceux qui veulent
supprimer le sénat
moi je ne veux pas supprimer le sénat je
veux le rénover et le moderniser
la droite veut supprimer
mon sens si françois fillon et président
de la république vu les soutiens qu'il a
au sénat je souhaite assurer je ne suis
pas sûr qu'ils s'engagent dans cette
direction mais je pense que ce serait
une erreur
à droite comme à gauche et des gens qui
veulent supprimer le bicamérisme je
pense ce serait une erreur maintenant si
vous me dites il faut que rien ne bouge
non on peut pas mettre un an et demi
pour voter une loi ce n'est pas possible
moi je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
qu'elle est chose qu'ils doivent avancer
moi je suis pour la suppression de la
dotation parlementaire de la réserve
parlementaire je le dis depuis longtemps
c'est éculés ça n'a plus aucun sens et
l'argent qui est donné à chaque sénateur
ou député pour financer des des bruits
des associations moi j'en donne pas
parce que je pense que c'est pas normal
c'est du clientélisme mais des mets y
compris des investissements dans les
mairies ferait mieux d'être attribué au
préfet pour augmenter la dotation aux
collectivités locales
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
avoir deux lectures trois relectures
pour un texte une lecture ça suffit je
pense que la procédure accélérée
d'antonio la procédure normale en fait
un aller retour et après on voit que les
conclusions s'assurer l'ère des réseaux
sociaux à l'ère des réseaux sociaux on
met un an et demi pour voter nul ou
presque vous espérez que françois
hollande si les candidats prennent pour
lui les mesures que vous voulez à nos
s'agissait en tout cas je sais que je
sais qu'il y aura un volet
institutionnel dans tous les candidats
je suis pour le maintien du sénat pour
la diminution du nombre
oui je crois pour la diminution du
nombre de députés de sénateurs sens on
peut faire des efforts pour qu'on ait
plus de moyens de contrôle
un peu comme il se passe au au sénat
américain de moyens de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement des moyens d'
expertise et puis que l'on voté la loi
un peu un peu plus vite et à partir de
là je pense que ça irait je ne suis pas
pour un sénat qui serait à la fois le
rassemblement comme le bundesrat
allemand
le rassemblement de tous les élus locaux
non moi je suis pour la limitation
drastique du cumul des mandats je suis
j'ai été cumulards et je suis pour un
mandat de parlementaire unique sans
aucun autre accompagnement
merci merci merci l'idée guillot merci à
vous nous aujourd'hui la semaine
prochaine mais c'est gérard larcher vous
avez évoqué il ya un instant qui sera
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
à tous et la semaine prochaine